today blue origin is often the laughing
stock of the space community
many people like to point out how blue
origin has yet to make any game-changing
progress
while having essentially unlimited
funding from jeff bezos
ironically though blue origin was
founded way back in september of 2000
which is almost two years earlier than
space x
but over the first 10 to 15 years of its
life most people didn't even know it
existed
recently though as spacex has garnered
worldwide attention for the outlandish
feeds
we are seeing more and more people look
into the private space industry
which has shined light onto blue origin
on top of this
jeff bezos just announced that he is
going to be stepping down from being
amazon's ceo
to fully focus on blue origin so does
blue origin
actually have a chance of meaningfully
competing against spacex
well starting off the first thing i
wanted to get out of the way
is that neither jeff bezos nor blue
origin is a joke
we all know that clip where jeff bezos
talks about throwing away a boeing 747
after using it
just like elon musk and there's also
that clip where elon musk is like
jefu but jokes aside jeff bezos is
not a joke by any means just like elon
musk he too has gone through massive
hurdles throughout his career
which he has successfully overcome time
and time again
for instance during the dot-com bubble
amazon stock crashed 95 percent
from 114 dollars to six dollars
meanwhile over half of all internet
companies went bankrupt
jeff bezos though cleverly managed to
pivot to cloud services with aws
which allowed amazon to grow into the
behemoth that it is today
with that being said let's take a look
at what blue origin is working on
today starting with project kuiper
project kuiper is basically a blue
origin slash
amazon's version of starlink through
kuiper they hope to provide global
broadband internet by launching
thousands of satellites
into space neither blue origin nor
spacex were the first to think of this
idea
satellite-based internet has been around
for decades and there are even full-on
companies dedicated to providing
satellite-based internet like vsat
the primary area in which blue origin
and spacex hope to improve upon the
competition
is implementation and execution you see
most satellite internet connections
today are extremely slow as we rely on
just a couple of satellites that are far
above the earth's surface
given that spacex and blue origin have
the ability to launch satellites
themselves
they can afford to launch thousands of
smaller satellites that orbit as close
to the surface
as possible thus providing much better
internet than the competition
spacex has already launched dozens of
star-like missions and are currently in
the process of launching a beta version
of starlink
meanwhile though blue origin amazon have
started testing some prototype
satellites
they have yet to launch a significant
amount of satellites for kuiper
this isn't that big of a deal though as
other than spacex
there is no competition nasa virgin
galactic and rocket lab
aren't looking to get into the satellite
internet business anytime soon
so it's really just blue origin and
spacex
aside from this amazon benefits from
massive leverage which spacex
does not have amazon already has over
150 million prime members worldwide
and i'd say that it's pretty likely that
amazon tries to leverage this customer
base to their advantage
amazon is already known for outstanding
customer service
so if amazon pushes their satellite
internet offering to their customers
it's likely that many will be quick to
jump ship from at t and spectrum and
other popular broadband internet
providers who don't have very good
customer service
something else to keep in mind is that
amazon will be able to subsidize the
cost for kuiper
unlike spacex spacex has to cover all of
the costs of developing
and launching starlink just from the
revenue that they receive from sterling
customers
as a result starlink is on the pricier
side coming in at 99
a month with amazon on the other hand
it's very possible they'll be able to
undercut spacex especially when it comes
to prime members
for instance they might be able to
charge 80 or even 60
a month and make up the difference
through all the purchases the given
prime member mix on amazon throughout
the year
as you can see it's likely that kuiper
will have a pretty good shot against
starlink despite their late entrance
moving on we have blue origin's other
major side project which is
their lunar landers in this realm it
seems like blue origin
is actually in the lead by quite an
amount blue origin revealed their lunar
lander blue moon nearly two years ago at
this point
and it was almost already complete way
back then
nasa has since already accepted blue
moon as an option to get cargo to the
moon
aside from this they're also working on
a human landing system in conjunction
with lockheed martin and a couple of
other companies
meanwhile nasa has given three companies
the opportunity to help them on their
2024 moon mission
which includes spacex blue origin and
dynetics
spacex is planning on developing a lunar
starship that can be used to land on the
moon
but currently they're still in the early
stages of developing starship
itself and i'm not quite sure if a lunar
starship will be crew ready by 2024
at the same time i'm also not sure if
nasa will be ready to launch the moon by
2024 in the first place
so maybe spacex does still have a chance
in scooping up this contract
as for dynamics they're taking a
completely different approach in spacex
and blue origin with their lunar lander
they've prioritized crew convenience and
practicality when designing their lander
which sits very close to the ground
however they also face one major
obstacle similar to spacex
which is that their lunar lander
requires refueling in space
dianetics is hoping to achieve this
ambitious goal by 2024
but it's definitely going to be
difficult to say the least considering
this
it looks like blue origin is a furthest
ahead when it comes to lunar lander
development
and they no doubt have the simplest
design so they have a pretty good
shot at being the ones helping nasa get
people back to the moon
now that we've covered their side
endeavors let's jump into their rocket
starting with a new shepard
new shepard is a relatively small rocket
designed to simply carry six passengers
into space for 11 minutes
with new shepard blue origin hopes to
provide researchers as well as space
enthusiasts the opportunity to
experience
just a little bit of space blue origin
has been testing this rocket for several
years now
and they have been saying that crude
missions are just around the corner for
quite some time
now but given the stellar track history
of the new shepard
i'm pretty confident it's going to
happen sooner rather than later
anyways like any other rocket new
chapter launches vertically
but after it reaches a certain altitude
its booster disconnects and comes back
to land on the surface
meanwhile the crew capsule continues
upwards and spends 11 minutes in space
before falling back into the earth's
atmosphere and slowly landing using
parachutes
this will be extremely easy to reuse and
quite appealing to individuals
interested in space tourism
spacex isn't really interested in space
tourism like
at all so the main competition for blue
origin here
is virgin galactic blue origin hasn't
revealed pricing yet
but we do know that a space flight with
virgin galactic costs 250 000
per ticket so i'd assume that blue
origin's price is about the same
as well the main difference between the
two offerings is really just a method in
which you get to space
do you want to experience a traditional
vertical rocket launch or would you
rather have a more flight-like
experience
given that that's really just a matter
of personal preference it's likely that
blue origin and virgin galactic will
dominate the space tourism industry
and finally that brings us on to blue
origin's most significant project
new glenn the new glenn is blue origin's
crown jewel
and it is their attempt to rival
spacex's starship rocket blue origin
expects that new glenn will have a
payload capacity of 45 metric tons in
low earth orbit
to put that in perspective tarship is
expected to have 100 metric tons of
payload capacity
so starship will also be far ahead of
new glenn but
it looks like new glenn will be the
closest competition blue origin mainly
hopes to use new glenn to establish
sustainable travel between the earth
and the moon at the end of the day this
video isn't really a question of will
blue origin survive
jeff bezos has more than enough money to
run blue origin for decades to come
rather the real issue this video is
addressing is whether or not blue origin
will emerge to become a major player
within the space industry
right now it seems like they are getting
crushed by spacex in terms of innovation
and that spacex will overpower them
moving forward as well
however as we saw in this video this is
really not the case because of one major
underlying factor
which is that jeff bezos and elon musk
have completely different visions
for space sure they're both developing
reusable rockets and trying to raise
money by launching satellite internet
but that's really where the similarities
end here's the thing
elon musk's primary goal is to expand
humans outside of earth and make humans
a multi-planetary species
conversely jeff bezos primary goal is to
utilize space to enrich our lives here
on earth you see jeff bezos points out
that the conditions everywhere outside
of the earth are terrible for human life
the truth is mars is a super cold
desolate rusty planet
establishing a convenient form of life
on mars will no doubt take hundreds of
years
if not thousands as a result jeff bezos
thinks it makes more sense to use space
to solve problems
on earth as opposed to trying to
colonize other planets
for instance he thinks it would be wise
to move manufacturing and energy
production
into space that way we wouldn't be
polluting the earth
this doesn't mean that he doesn't want
humans to colonize other planets though
in fact he wants to establish a
permanent lunar base
however this would be more for research
and potential tourism purposes
as opposed to permanent living purposes
this fundamentally different approach
has left blue origin
and spacex on radically different paths
which are both
extremely important so in the end does
blue origin actually have a chance in
the space industry
in my opinion the answer is absolutely
as spacex and blue origin
are more like puzzle pieces that fit
together and fulfill different purposes
in the base industry
as opposed to something like nasa versus
russia during the cold war
do you guys agree that blue origin has a
bright future comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys think blue
origin deserves more credit than they
receive
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you